all right hey we are live Happy New Year
and welcome back to the campfire the
last word with Lord kognito Andy Barr
tez
it's been a while I get the chance to
talk to my brethren the cheetah the
ninjas back so we ready man we are ready
what is going on even it has been a
minute we got talks of desti man yeah we
have been off a little bit I did some
traveling a lot of driving around and we
had holidays and family time which is
always good take a little break we had a
little a pretty steady same thing going
on there destiny for a little while
which we still get to talk about but
yeah we're we're back
get a little change this week by little
I'm not lying yeah we kind of are
looking forward to what's coming in the
future but yeah like right now there is
some interesting discussion within the
community between certain people in the
community and lots about like where
we're at like there's there's a lot
going on right now it's it's more a what
would be a relatively quiet time
literally just the last week in the
dawning not much on the calendar for a
couple of weeks there's a lot of
discussion which is always an
interesting time yes sir game of what a
what's going on we all loud people yeah
man it's a big man it's been you know
had some time off you know it was funny
because I think I messaged you a week
early and I had like last word panic
attack because if we do we miss do you
know we go we good so yeah it was good
but it was good to have some time off it
was good to spend time with family
friends dude new years to the holiday do
that whole bit and then I'm like you
said I mean you know we're playing here
and there you know fairly consistent I
would say and um like to discuss we got
an exotic quest we gonna discuss we're
gonna talk about the community right now
is a there's a big split right now with
a lot of things going on and Dom yeah
man I can't wait to jump right into a
man so let's get to it brother then
let's say feet already asking questions
what are you talking about he said um I
have a quick question anyone helping me
Father grind out his Mountain
mountaintop quest
however I know the second portion
required fabled incomp will it count for
last season or laughter and he's gone so
within the current season
it is within the current season for
those quests though if you had a hit
have to hit a certain rank same thing
applies to say like Python and gambit
you got to get heroic or whatever it is
for the same thing it's got to be within
that season because at the end of the
season it resets so just because you
didn't reset before it doesn't hold at
that checkbox unless you're on that step
you have to be on the step and move
through it yes that is correct
gotta get that mountaintop man-eating of
those like how have you done on the
ritual weapons this season
got them all and got none got none I had
no desire for any of them imma be honest
with you I mean the closest one was
probably the shotgun from gambit no and
I've actually dated some stairs I may be
about 75% rule but I kind of stopped
playing gambit and I've really been on a
fractal line obelisk kick yeah so
everything for me it's been about that
doing those bounties which tend to be
lengthy right they're like you know
they're not hard right like I don't like
a hundred it's like kill six thousand of
this enemy I know that's a lot like 300
sell or 180 precision cabal kills with a
bow that takes a minute
it takes a minute you know and what's
funny is I started to formulate spots in
destiny but specific farming and one of
my favorite spots right now is the EDC
now you know when the EDC will tell you
to spot drops where they start like
fighting each other that's perfect wrong
he'd fallen in Kabal kills o3o COBOL
super like void kills so I've been doing
that saint-14 bounties been knocking all
that stuff out and here we go here fart
a guy in a li takes ten minutes to
complete pro well you got the most
efficient strategies that's cool I'm
just telling you the spot I like to
multi test cuz I could do two or three
things at one time like I said I got
about kabah got my fall in there I get
super kills and what I like is there's
so many patrol beacons in that little
area around where Devon is at with the
church I do that then you got the lost
sector underneath I do that so it's like
I get everything is like the leaders I
get the most of all of those those
sundial bounties done you know I mean so
right now all my obelisks are done level
11 or herbalist ain't ready to go the
only thing I really need
bad though II which I really when I'm
jealous out the carboxyl I'm you
probably have it too as I got to get my
battle pass up to 92 so I can get the
extra per yeah I'm working on them and
like I mean like this ad
yeah like I'm probably I'm innocent so
yeah yeah I guess well so those final
grants will be doubly beneficial is then
you literally have a close to look at
basically no frog hold on we have Lords
of gaming editor-in-chief ancient of
frost just reading in the building
you said wouldn't it be better if you
could organize all the activity bounties
on the quest screen so then you can see
what you have in a single activity what
you feel about that II what you feel
about that a whole tray of course we'd
like to have a little little choice in
how we organize our bounties as opposed
to wherever the hell they end up
sometimes like oh I baked something they
haven't moved like mmm I mean sometimes
just like why does that even happen
that's just so weird oven moves or
requests that I was working on jump to
the other page or yeah it's it's nothing
you don't have as much choice over how
that thing organizes itself you just
kind of have to hunt and peck wherever
it's at oh yeah I'm not the biggest
thing you can only track one bounty I'm
like you're telling me I can't list it
like yeah guys one and then there's not
a way to just bring up bounties without
like going between the modifiers if
you're looking at that and got a switch
that it's not I'm get me started on a
tryouts - yeah oh God tracking one
trying to track one triumph like come on
he's like my wife been out of season
before half she can't find Jack freaking
out
wishing he's rich activity is it's a bit
of a slog I agree with you on that man
and now that Tim comes to like new
players as well there was uh another
girl I was helping her build a computer
and then her husband got into destiny
too at the same time as she was doing it
she was building a computer and then
he's playing through like kind of like
new light and it's just totally lost
like completely doesn't know where to go
a lot from an a to not entirely sure
when things unlock wind wire how I
haven't gone through that experience
because I don't have enough time to play
the characters I have I haven't made a
fourth one just for you know messing
around sake but yeah I'm not sure that
experience is the most welcoming for
because there's a lot of people just
like hey thanks for this video thanks
for explaining this one and I'm just
like that was basic stuff and I can
probably do more basic because the
questions on comments are like we don't
know what's going on we don't know
what's going on you don't know that's
why I've always say you have a place in
the community like again the way you
explain and break things down it's just
like man like but someone who has it
who's gonna even if you've just gone
away for a little bit cuz I acted now
use drew from the obelisks I was like
what is going on with these obelisks
like just as far as on the resonance
then the sequence to do it which one
pertains to which activity and also arm
which wants to focus on first because
there's ones that actually give you more
drops at the sundial so I you help me
plan an attack so I was like you know
what let me do it especially eight easy
one because God knows that that they
need to be fixed with long enough it was
even out of order but as soon as I had
enough iMac never looked back I just
bought it all in the mouth I was out and
I was so glad when the Tower one came
because then I can grab the bounties
from the tower one for me to you know
say I don't have to go to the EDC once
it was finished like I started on
bounties oh my god I wish I buy those
somewhere like can there be a bounteous
tab on the director screen every vendors
bounties just put him in like I don't
care if there's less reasons to go to
the tower but just like why can't I just
not buy them over and over from there
cuz you're just you can't be in like a
strike place and be like oh let me pick
up another bounty cool no I gotta go fly
back to the tower
I gotta fly back here shot the combat so
he's always been preaching this bounties
in space that's his motto that's his
modeling I got a [ __ ] on this my ship
can communicate with the tower let me
pick those bounties up come on we can
send you no space transmissions were in
the freakin space magic future
yeah we need art is the same thing yeah
we need more room for bounties yeah if
you got a bunch of quest especially it
gets like an alternate character that's
got like ten exotics that you haven't
just done again on that character mm-hmm
it's got to be a memory constraint it's
got to be it dick I can't think of no
other reason as to why then please blow
up the end
higher game for destiny priests who are
not held back by old consoles that's all
I gotta say is I do not want consoles I
don't care if there's 106 PlayStation
hundred six million Playstations out
there well any man independent studio
brother I was like then give me see a
bigger vault if you can freakin handle
it I don't care anymore you want an
unfair advantage
he bought is that what we saying oh we
want you you you're Busey PC self wants
extra extra things that the console
warriors can't have is that what we
doing what a version of a game is not
identical on a different system yes 100%
I damn sure do it's to a point of like
our
I mean I didn't intend to talk about
armor 2.0 get to it because you have
like okay now I have my season of darn
armor dawn armor I'm getting it my void
set from the season pass at least that
one's actually worth considering the
master work because it's got good stat
rules on it but that's the only way to
get that's overwhelm it you're gonna
master work something you're gonna swing
those with s materials boo boo materials
that's the free shots I gotta feel but
that rule is I gotta be honest if I pull
it from the season pass and it's like
all mobility and strength I'm gonna
shove my head through my monitor but
that's a different problem Wow chat
document this it is the New Year's the
10th it's 9:20 a.m. Eastern he boxes is
going to master work and armor and
utilize his materials document this day
I never thought this but wow wow this is
wow this is special this is we started
off the new year right new you new year
new year new yeah like I'm going like
it's like fitness slogans in here so
what's the problem that is go the best
that role that you're gonna get it comes
from the damn season pass you can't
grind that stuff out basically anywhere
else outside of raids an iron banner and
apparently reckoning which I still have
got to try ah vagabond oh I know you
argue master worked we talked about this
the other day a vagabond over be a petty
Salaam Louis and
but then like all these but you're still
if you want to take advantage of all the
mods you're gonna get a solar set you're
gonna need a void set and then you have
three characters so that's nine sets of
armor per season or if you were really
if I'm just not saying I'm close to
doing this but if you were really trying
to be like hey I always want to be
functional I don't know what mods are
gonna stay these are new season of dawn
mods do they stay do they go they
literally say season of dawn okay I have
the ones from undying I've got that one
season 10 is coming that's gonna have
another icon
yeah I probably have too many weapons
but there's I mean if this cycle
continues yeah in the arms in your vault
space is gonna be an issue the armored
situation is gonna be a problem the
seasonal slot is the only compounding it
even more mm-hmm
I agree I agree they they they have to
think about a long-term solution cuz
with this current model this is going to
really do a lot of add a lot of weight
to that that vault because we're gonna
need set for to hold on for everything
you know I'm saying so yeah and it comes
down to goes back to your initial point
last last word which was about exotics
needing to have that universal arm slot
functionality so that they have it so
yeah I mean we gotta see that they got
to figure out something in that cuz it's
just not sustainable let's just call it
what it is if they're gonna continue
this model you know in each season
having a specific mod slot you know we
you know it's not gonna be sustained at
all so yeah I did master work my first
exotic is my NASA Rick sin my custom
isn't breed all know how many two golf
balls right two golf balls at the top
I had like a great intellect at roll
that's before it started dink it was
like 6e
I mean if it's an even 60 plus yeah go
nuts I mean yeah I had to it was like if
it's like you know it got the right role
it has as far as in election discipline
which is what cuz I want to get my
abilities in actually yeah where's the
boy dude it was it was it was I
everything lined up and that's the to be
honest that's the only one that I used
your exotic I used for my voice last I
really don't use I fall in love with
Nazareth right now so um yeah that
that's that's been the one I've done
with that and then it's a other than
I've prisms to cuz it's like instead of
one in oh boy yeah and to pursue shards
or something insane it wasn't she no it
would not cheat your Walker and be like
oh look at my blinking the rest of your
body is like a homeless person exactly
so I did that you don't say but um what
I wasn't sorry sorry what I wanted to
talk about nobody jumped off an arm
again but we gotta talk about this
this ruler we saving that devil for me
going at that devil throw that quest
we got time from getting there I
understand like to see what does we
continue your males will say wait now
we've started it so go into it we have a
new exotic quest quest thoughts on your
experience sir I'd love to know the fold
as you was it a long hard grind do you
have it argues or needs to get this
weapon it was it was killer man I had to
use all my resources put aside so much
time just to do this difficult think I
work shot if you have got seed I know
I'm plugging I'm shamefully plugging my
website but if you have not seen my
article and runs the game with that net
in reference to this quest please do it
so it's up there right now about the
devil's ruin and I basically the titles
like Devils ruin people are upset for
the wrong reasons now listen
I get it you know the quest itself is a
job for an exotic quest as far as to fix
your face ever Smurfs but as far as in
comparison to other course cuz we know
we used to Yahoo no lengthy backtracking
multiple things killing multiple enemies
no you literally jump in the game tells
you that the quest is live you go to the
sundown first what the game incorrectly
tells you that you got to kill all these
champions right for for Devil's ruin
which it has nothing see on that do it I
was like wait a minute
mm-hmm okay before it takes to look
great on cuca thank you but I appreciate
it man I really appreciate the support
on that article um yes so pretty much
get on your going that you login you
start you do sundial you don't even have
to do legendary sundown you do regular
sundown you do that you finish it
there's no amount of champions that you
need to kill as soon as it's over it
says hey you have the frame or whatever
it may be just start the quest now from
that point you go to the same fourteen
saying fourteen then tells you about
Twilight gap at a time loss frame then
from there you go to a special Twilight
gap mission where you have to literally
just go around searching for these
crucible rope
Kuzma robots all across the map it's
about ten and it says your tip 11 drops
and the glasses oh so I get the
frustration I should say for sure I get
people who are sooo are saying this is a
joke you know there are people that are
very upset that were like you know this
is what we're doing for an exotic quest
you know I'm saying this is not an
unacceptable and they're not wrong
all I'm saying is they're looking at it
wrong because when I did that quest
right yes I was surprised when they
dropped but I was so amazed by something
that I've always wanted in destiny which
is a subtle thing which was voice banter
or during the quest between first Osiris
and Saint which we complained about
since Saint has come home no there has
been no interaction between these two
it's supposed to be his long long lost
bromance and no one's talking to each
other he just shows up in the tower we
don't hear from Osiris again that kind
of a deal so they hid him talking was
number one was dull - you know let's put
out I mean I'm not I'm not buying I'm
not myelin games but I know about some
twilight gap Twilight gap is a very
important mission in destiny very in the
history of the law what happened there
it affected the relationship of shacks
in Saladin and in safale because the
city was about to be overthrown by the
falling Shack broke protocol did not
listen to the violence Allen when to
defend the city on his own his own
specific way he ended up saving the city
but as a result they don't really mess
with him knowing they they're not close
the Titans is all there's a little beef
with the Titans right now and I'm saying
but that's why shacks is my face but I
you know I like the Exiles like I was
honest execs out he don't listen to the
speaker
you know say and then I like shacks he's
like no we're not listening to you this
is what we're doing and we're gonna save
this city so shacks is my favorite tight
period right
oh hey Fred any interaction between
brother Vance and Osiris yet Noah Cyrus
he's filed
sad vans but anyway back on track so we
got that um they had some great
interaction they're just you hear Osiris
talk about the smallest if you guys
haven't on the mission I'm sorry yeah
we've got that done the mission right
now come on it's easy you know a so just
a solemn list they talk about that day
they go back it's like two veterans by
y'all we lost mad people that war you
know man so it's cool to get that
interaction then as you get the final
one then the magic happens and your
voice shacks is on the calls he's like
wait a minute
Guardian is those there's no the
crucible maximal to be scheduled that I
like that what are you doing there you
know and it's the first time sacks and
say forty or talking to each other it is
but as a warlocks malarious i sat down
it says you know what this is a Titan
day I gotta respect this right here it
is dope could say forties been away so
long
and he's asking like oh you run the
crucible now what's going on then and
he's how I heard you give away weapons
he like no no no they're earned so it's
like this banter of like yo Hall of Fame
like I'm running running this my way
again so this is Titan talk I'm just
saying it was a two hundred second timer
and I had no problem waiting to see if
there was it was great but it's just to
hear them go back and forth then you got
the song and you know we got that it was
just so dope and it was almost like the
game within the game cuz they say 14
starts talking about all the pinnacle
weapons or heard about tenet Volker what
is this I heard you give out this other
what what is invoker what does it do it
shoots bullets it's so funny between
these two men and I just love it so I me
again fan tact like I've always wanted
these kind of things from destiny and
I'm saying so again if you look at the
quest from a you know difficulty
standpoint yeah I could see someone
being disappointed but if you're looking
for pure lore that's the stuff I want
more like multiple of the of the major
characters in a room in a cinema or just
talking to each other that is fire and I
love him and it
a great great little nuance and I had no
problem I'm good to you II I mean you
know obviously did DD you know not
everyone agrees with me you know Sammy
this article is but a little controversy
in the comments but um what did you feel
overall about the quest and then
obviously you know everything associated
with it
uh yeah I finished the sundial picked it
up and it's like okay and then it's like
okay go talk to same a little next wall
Denis 8:14 their login to well I kept
and I was like were the enemies nobody
to shoot I'll shoot baby I'm like mosey
around like oh what's this thing on the
ground interact like oh and I just went
around trying to find them all I did the
thing twice back to back cuz my first
recording of my video is gonna do for it
I didn't like so I literally went to the
sundial on a second character and
finished that quest and still got that
video up within like a couple hours of
oh yeah is Matt quit it's so fast so
mm-hmm
here's the idea of setting expectations
mm-hmm we have had an arc week box on a
calendar before here we go yeah there we
go we have had we have had the undying
mind on a calendar before at a biggie
we're stuck I guess it's for one of them
setting expectations when you say exotic
quest to sidearm to it they could have
taken exactly what you wanted those lure
bits the discussion and stuff and split
it between like a couple segments or
something like that mm-hmm
maybe there's a point where you pick up
the gun it's just the side arm point and
maybe there's a mode or like you know
you you kill some enemies you piece
together like and it you're you could
still be in the same damn area
you killed a certain number of enemies
okay hey now you've got some fragments
now we got to get this now we got to get
the rest of the pieces so you're gonna
have some enemies in there you fight
them now you start actually shooting
bullets about it then you you know
collect a little bit more you get the
laser attachment to go with it so you
actually like kind of get the other
functionality as opposed to here's ten
fragments here's your gun like kind of
break down and actually show somebody
and be like instead of somebody having
to go in the description figure out that
I actually have to hold it down do that
little bit of almost like an intro
weapon like the same way you got
introduced to your subclasses you're
like you can throw supers like you're
going out of your mind because use light
right recharge constantly and you're
like okay okay more functionality with
the weapon yeah oh yeah something
actually once you get it something to do
with it I mean the same thing as like if
you get a super here like okay now
there's a crap-ton enemies coming at you
but you're gonna be imbued with like
constantly when you stand in these pools
go nuts have a little bit of fun hey
here's this new sidearm okay maybe you
got to go and do a little bit of target
practice or maybe you gotta do this like
laser and like practice actually firing
the thing or maybe list just some way to
take you through a bit more because if
it's just go in find 10 robots and do
that trust me I absolutely loved the
commentary I was dying I'm pretty sure I
left out loud a couple of times like
legit I was like in my chair just I did
it twice and I was I listened to the
whole thing both times I love that part
loved I have no question that was great
I want to see more of that type of stuff
I would love to just have that stuff
sometimes just like out of nowhere just
even if it's like even like a byph
storyboard type cutscene mm-hm or it's
just like somebody in the tower and
they're kind of putting pictures back
and forth and there's this discussion
that happens for the week same thing as
you're saying with like Osiris insane if
after that say if like when you log in
on Friday at reset
when he was in the tower rise just a
little bit of discussion between a man
even it doesn't it's just art doesn't
have to be for like rendered videos just
like art hates shaking hands and they're
talking oh it's good to see you
we'll go to the tower I'm not welcome
there but you should still be going
there don't mind a place I can get some
type of this is what like they want in a
like narrative built game it can't just
be like he's in the tower yeah more of a
transition and then okay so you got an
exotic quest like okay you want this
type of banner when you get done with
the quest take it back and have those
two talking back and forth to each other
on the problems a little bit have me use
the weapon a little bit more those are
the types of things that I know it's
still not easy to do but I'm not talking
about fully rendered cinematics I'm
taking like two or three pieces of art
and those artists are beasts like
probably put together two or three
pieces just even if you're back and
forth on a dialogue a little split
screen just like we are right now to say
you know st. and shacks are talking and
it's like you know shacks pops out no
Cyrus pops and what are you doing and
crucible and like oh you could do it the
same way but show something as opposed
to just voiceover mmm
but what about resources II what about
what about that there's no more
Vicarious Visions
there's no more activision this is like
three more this is little o Bungie T's
did hey resources alone I remember a
certain darkest voice lines you have
already expecting stuff now you have the
voice lines I'm not asking for fully
rendered cinematics some little bit it
like literally I'm not saying those
artists completely oh here's our chord
see you if somebody was like two or
three storyboards that's not gonna that
shouldn't be killing anybody
it's a studio man mean so did you buy
themselves you know they could be just
for all I care there are ways to do that
just to give it a little bit of life so
there is expectation from you now from
from Bungie did are you
actually saying that day there are some
things that you can demand from I'm
shocked by this is whatever you see it a
become Wow expectation provoked a little
Oh Bungie I'm good I'm glad that you've
come around that's what I'm talking
about I have no problem with that
I'm glad you see the light my brother
I'm glad you're there
listen I agree you know at the end of
the day you know we still feel they're
getting close but they're transitioning
still needs to get these little pieces
the same thing undying mind same thing
now and say comes and Osiris or whatever
you know just just a little bit more and
then it'll be a more seamless tapestry
right as opposed to these kind of rough
cuts and then you wake up and he's oh
he's here he's in power okay that's cool
but how do you get here let's be and I
got it I got a really defend you now
let's really be real as much as I love
that voice Benton how in the hell shacks
did not know st. 14 was in the towel not
in the towel
let's be how did he when he's on the
comms Oh saint-14
no I thought you were dead like bro we
within the tower for like a week
Brooklyn what are you talking about he
got he he set up shop with where were
you should've noticed that's not that
big people talk somebody's like some
little you know some in random unknown
NBC walks don't be like oh hi I'm st. 14
hey chefs have you met st. 14 oh that
happens we know I'm not in the game when
with the cats are away the NPC's will
play I'm sure they speak to say say is
talking about all the children he meets
that want him D to carry him no child
went back to shacks clearly it said that
Yoda is this cool do even Zavala who is
right on the same bridge as st. was like
yo that was a good job you did Guardian
bringer I don't know how you did it but
everyone knows except Shaq's ridiculous
maybe it is a running joke I mean shout
out to tell maybe it did you maybe they
will be a circus
I hope they would be a sarcastic you
know zip first I'm like Shaq's how do
you not know your man sits back like
come on now
but anyway other than that yes low
storyboard will be cool you know if they
can't do a cinematic you know just
transitioning the pieces and then they
gotta but I think overall I still like
but we're gonna get to the main thing
right bash it is the same way what do
you think
Bastian can't be the same way oh now I'm
not a patient yeah I've been at
expectation the expectation train with
me now this is great all I'm saying is
this was cute you can't run this car two
times now Bastian has to be something
substantial now let's get to it and I
want to dive right in if you don't mind
which is have you seen glads tweet
barrage you see yeah actually DM no can
no shower Glee yes you actually
responded to it yes yes you know um you
know glad has some things to say and um
do you want to actually I would let you
read you what I read it if you know I
was like I'm looking but you can general
yeah generally you know what he's saying
is this he's like look you know I'm
finding it harder to play you know as a
hardcore destiny player there's not
enough challenge it feels like he used
the word casualization you know I'm
saying being casual feels overly casual
you know and if me you know maybe it's a
result of this new season pass structure
he's a little concern shout the bro man
he had a very similar video as well
mentioning that and um you know it's one
of the somebody's talking about some
father losing his job that's hilarious
oh but you know back on point with this
thing is you know because of things like
the devil's ruin with the ease of
getting it and even let's talk about
legendary sundown me you both talked
offline no matchmaking you know um that
there was no reason there should not be
matchmaking in the sorry little
matchmaking casual discussion aside for
a second there is a moral reason that
should not have matchmaking unless they
just want to make pinnacles unmatch made
yeah because there's no matchmaking in
the dungeon there's no matchmaking in
the REA is there a pinnacle for
legendary folks oh no yeah you get one
is it yeah I got one penny was it good
make sure your heavy weapon I think it's
mom
I think it's Mars wherever obviously the
line in the sand somebody who correct me
faster than I can remember but whichever
one has line in the sand you can
guarantee yourself a pinnacle heavy
which is hard to do we always say it
again when you get to the end of sundial
pinnacle a little wet like when you get
to pick whichever weapons if you're
fully maxed it should be about oh yes
one of them is gonna be pinnacle
powerless so when I got to the whole
legend it was just pick something at 962
and pick one of us so if you need a
heavy slot which a lot of people need
that one filled for pinnacles that's the
one you go for a ride right right right
right
I got [ __ ] okay fair enough fair though
yeah I mean it gives no armor sadly
there's no armor sadly but it is what it
is put on yeah it's like you know there
wasn't and then also let's be real it
was it no specific reward like or led to
an exotic quest uh I mean even Menagerie
had didn't have truther so I had the
what you call it associated with it be
catalyst Izanagi catalyst the menagerie
so it need to have that so again the the
consensus seems to be from the community
and I'ma throw it back to you is right
now they feel we're going down the
casual train again and the hardcore are
upset so I'm gonna bring it to you E is
this fair and you know do you yourself
find yourself struggling to play in the
current season annual pass bottom I am
curious about what you have
it's a weird space right now because
something like the sundial weapon grind
is really good to try and get a role
here like I have six roles when you get
to season past 92 I can get eight
freaking roles on it so I'm really going
for certain guns I got pretty high
chances but you know at some point the
dice might roll pretty close to what I'm
looking for I might not get the right
barrel but I can probably get those
perks that I'm looking for
but in turn once you get those you're
like okay what do I do
or do I really really care about those
rolls to grind that same one activity
600 times trying to get a roll on this
one steel feather repeater trying to get
that feeding frenzy multi kill clip that
I want mm-hm
how much do I care mm-hmm and it's like
where is what is your motivation that
whatever I had is that steel feather
repeater gonna do anything that I don't
have already maybe a fraction better hmm
maybe but can't I just go into my vault
and probably pull something's gonna be
fairly close indecent probably so again
where is the drive and I was like I mean
all three glads whole thing so you got a
third on Twitch nice guy we actually
actually made up going on he may have
been a little out of it but we always
remember me we had a lot of weird jokes
we are over 21 damnit yes yes so this is
just straight up for me him and it's
like and honestly it's like this is one
of the reasons honestly glad is just
like a cool dude is because he can be
goofy has some of the weirdest tweets
I've ever seen I never know what to
expect and they're hilarious but it's
like when when big people in the
community to go candid like this it's
nice to see mm-hm so my concern with
destiny right now is that it doesn't
really feel like the games come content
contains satisfaction for a long time
dedicated destiny players I almost feel
the separate that separation again in
quotes ah and a full towards a casual
sized model dripping content season
seems drawn out and slow quests have
become very short and easy to do
Pinnacle weapons even lost their name
and don't have unique perks like in the
past these same weapons become easier
and easier to acquire each season
grinding rank in the crucible is easier
and faster than ever even for casual
crucible players after day one all wreck
um all raids become easy and a one
facing becomes normal strat for lots of
groups there's just no actually
difficult content everything is easy
we are so over leveled in every activity
compared to the combatants where's the
overwhelming feeling at where that
feeling when stuff that wasn't fed
slowly and we were able to go out go
about activities as we please
hmm when things were rough and had
difficulty to them it's like where were
things when they were rough things have
difficulties the idea of armor - armor
2.0 and the artifact is great but
sometimes the question of execution
overall there are so many of us out
there that live and die by the hand of
Bungie and destiny we want challenging
secrets we want intriguing quests and
grinds when it feels like things are
dumbed down and hand out to everyone the
passion fades give us that magic and
that's indictment but I mean it is well
said it's like the mad I mean honestly
for destiny - the magic of Destiny one
has been honestly questionable if it's
been fully recaptured there have been
moments playing but this time when
shattered throne was found that was
pretty unique for everybody whisper the
worm-like there have been moments of
magic like that but the grinds have
still felt different and they still
haven't quite got I mean some of the
rituals like okay it's the mountaintop
well I finally got it boy I nearly
killed myself trying to it's been but
they don't even have they don't have
those anymore they're pulling away from
those and it's just like yeah go shoot
some stuff - with the shotgun for a
Python go linear fusion and crucible
which nobody wants to do was to do I did
it I didn't want to do it sorry our
ballista and they got big guns not even
that Komodo I don't hate anybody yelling
from the mountaintops about Komodo I
mean it's a linear fusion and crucible
you have a couple more shots but it's
not like it bodies or anything I mean
really what is your time is not well
spent doing that what's the what's the
unique perk oh there's no that's none is
just best roles right it has to do
things yeah it might have later no
distractions or something where is it
I'm gonna blind the damn thing actually
own it earlier in the season
there it is red guy so you got I have a
storm moving target tolerated coils
malignant rifling with the charge time
masterwork so
yeah I mean it's a 466 linear fusion
nothing really special just literally I
have the storm in a moving target and
you can switch one of the perk a forget
what those other two are but mmm-hmm
overall I mean I even said this to you
and like before we got sided and I was
just like even for me when I log in I'm
kind of like I'm doing it too late I'm
trying to get the daunting bounty so my
season pass can get up there so at least
that can be done but man when my season
pass gets up to like 92 I am not pressed
to do a lot for like two months because
I mean well you got legend sundial if
you do it once on each character there
is absolutely zero reason to do it then
what rewards do not change you do not
get anything unique from it it is just
harder so if you do it one two three
times one pinnacle per character you are
out mm-hmm and that's like okay let's
finish I'm like there used to be a
reason to grind and get late there's no
better rolls there's no chance that like
higher stat rolled armor there is
nothing in that activity and there's
things they could put in there for a
pinnacle
no I mean how much have you been playing
I want to ask you a couple questions
first something's burning in my head is
based on past conversations we've had so
what about you know hey take a break
play other games debating on it actually
I really haven't because I remember
certain someone did 20:19 I would say
these things and he would say look man
it's okay and no but that's take a break
that's the point I'm getting dude I'm
late debating him like if I stream on
Saturday I'm like maybe I'm gonna play
inside I'm just gonna buy that in one
session man there's there's a three
testicle yeah I know I was like I played
limbo on the plane and literally got
home from the flame and finished like
the last thirty minutes because I wasn't
done
but inside yeah I want to play that and
there's some other bigger games like
every soft and if it was just like if I
have a consistent stream schedule maybe
like you know Saturday afternoon ever
you three or four hours like I'm gonna
work your breath little wild like
there's some big ones that I want to
play
what's up which will how you doing happy
new you wishful and it's because like my
time spent is uh I mean where were you
gonna have your fun and that's again the
point of like how much new like am I
gonna do nightmare hunts am I gonna do
raids am I gonna do I don't have as much
of a like group to play with even
probably like you do like I've got an
awesome like discordant community if I
reach out wings came together pretty
good but it simply don't just have like
hey a group on Tuesday that knows gonna
be on that I'm gonna play with you
integration like I don't have that
regular group that was also in destiny
was the most fun for me as win it was
like hey Tuesday's we're raiding were
knocking on ball to glasses doing we're
seeing what happens or going through it
a couple times
what about laying together on to
salvation how have you I mean me and you
did that together but my question is
that one time one time but but I guess
my question again is like no incentive I
mean it still exists paid of heresy
still exist no incentive for you to want
to do those activities anymore
I mean some of its for the challenge
like if I want to go do pit of heresy
solo I wouldn't mind doing that I've
been busier wear it so if I was like
I've been busier and that's just like
life and work and stuff like that so I
get there as opposed to spending hey I'm
gonna spend half a day on this stuff
it's like I just have it as much time to
be like I want to sit down and also just
been trying to like hang a little more
friends and hanging with my wife more
stuff like that so it's like am I gonna
go spend 12 hours working on this
dungeon and like try and find my way
through multiple times beating vote poor
Jeff prettiest name or do I just want to
like hey play for a couple hours work on
some casual stuff and then you know
maybe go hang out with both my wife wife
watch a movie know and have dinner
mm-hmm it's
because if I feel like I do that I don't
feel like I'm missing as much right now
and that's where again the casual it's
like I got my quest in a day it's not
like hey I know this quest is gonna take
you know what daily reset you got to do
it five times so I got to make sure I
log in so I get as quick as I can I got
to do this step over three weeks I got
to go grind a lot of stuff like I know
as soon as I was done I had legend
sundial we like goofed once and that was
done no it's like I got one and you're
like why would you go back well you
wouldn't and then definitely I was like
and then you look on the calendar it was
like we had 21 days until Bastion and
now I have 20 days and there's nothing
new coming hmm we're about to lose the
dawning no we're gonna have even less
going on there's literally gonna be like
not but there's just basics I mean true
just like destiny basics for two weeks
before Bastien comes out and for bashing
we don't know if that's gonna be a one
day thing
yeah month yeah you're going almost a
whole month then we're gonna get the
Imperium foundation towards the end but
man this January in flake if Bastian is
light that is a base empty that's a
pretty empty Mamta mouth
I mean that's where it's like I was is
my season or as high as it should be
okay cool I got that I can grind some
stuff if I log in and do a couple
sundial runs and I'm like okay it's been
like you know an hour to got like eight
drops on each one I got like a hundred
weapons to pick from Nutr great all
right let me tap out for the day but I
don't have that incentive to go grind or
write I agree I agree yeah I mean listen
this is valid you know you're valid I'm
not saying glad is wrong I
we have had real you have have a
complete almost a complete role reversal
four to eight IT
to dance with it so I think this is
hilarious because every time I hear you
you sound more like me in 2019 and I
sound more like you in 2020 here's my
thing you know I've come full circle Vee
and I basically I'm like look
there by himself right there is no shout
to say Allah no say don't rage he's been
killing it with the podcast lately and
I'll try to listen to him as much as I
can he made a good point and it comes
down to resources right you know during
that time you know when we had menagerie
and all that stuff you had you know
Vicarious Visions all these other places
they would outsource these is content
with right so I'm looking at it coming
in to shadow keep on my okay boom we got
raid garner salvation raid we got pit of
heresy you know we had the low activity
with the vex offensive okay cool
you know nobody was going crazy about
season on there but as far as attack
from activities nightmare hunts we had a
bunch of activity right so I said to
myself what season of the Dorn starts we
both said to ourselves right
realistically what can we expect right
we both said Naomi no ray we both said
hang on B no dungeon right so how are
they gonna keep us invested right so now
it's like this slower not difficult but
this slower kill a thousand things we
don't kill four hundred things duty
sundown runs in the sundown let's be
real so now it's not difficult right I
can please do it in 15-20 minutes you
know so the way I look this is how I'm
and this is what I'm looking at and how
I'm hoping this thing go
this is how I feel is going to be where
we're gonna get the expansion which is
our big chunk
and then these little spa season of
season of I think we're gonna it's gonna
be like this is like the break this is
halftime we had the first to court date
this is half now we gotta wait now I
don't know we don't know what the name
of the next season is I don't even know
what today we don't know what's going on
right so what I'm hoping is that the
next season we cannot go both of like re
the guest is most likely trials is
coming back right let's just guess let's
put it out there Charles is coming back
he's building this he don't like shacks
the way shacks running out these weapons
he gonna build his own thing he wants to
build this beacon he keeps talking about
a beacon right Osiris him his buddy he's
running around with Osiris logos in the
tower
he's building a spot and we're gonna
most likely the rumor is what is it five
thousand frak the line we're gonna need
for something here in foundation but the
imperium foundation this is there's
definitely gonna be some renaissance of
trials we're building trials Lorelai
right I'm cool with the narrative aspect
of building I like that
however I knew this season is going to
piss off the hardcore the hardcore are
gonna come in there and we're gonna
blaze out and you're kind of gonna be
done quickly the thing the thing that
they're gonna have to do is they got to
be very careful during what I consider
this is the halftime season the next
season has to have they got a happen if
you could have a gap you got to still
have substantial content I'll give you
the gap but next season we gotta have
trials but we got also have something
else
and I'm saying cuz otherwise people are
gonna drop and gnats it's a it's it's
not fair unfortunately it's not fair
because they are just who they are but
if you want to retain your base
you gotta do something you know I'm
saying now all I'm saying this whatnot
is where I'm gonna get at them what I'm
saying is for this dawning and let's be
real I love the doughnut but let's be
real this dawning none of the fly stuff
could be earned everything and
outrageous prices let's be wherever
Tessa's out here running wild and she
got the hottest things in the store
she's got the hottest ships she got the
hottest outfits she's got every fly a
frosted hardlight you know on a sword
everything is spectacular for like $10 a
pop she's out here right so for all this
money you're making I would like to see
some return investment in content cuz
y'all out here while let's me this is
the most egregious test has been in a
while and not only daddy you can't even
really earn practice like that I tested
you're dealing anymore whatever you have
it slowly just gonna roll you're right I
know I gotta be finicky cuz I was like
I'm gonna stop my BS with the little
$200
oh great Martin's doing I stopped to do
me I stopped my foolishness I said you
know what I have 5,000 um brightness I
looked at e the new dawning model that's
6,000 right
I said all right I'm gonna save up I
want to see how long this gonna take me
bro
that little amount of bright dust you
get for those little daunting bounties
or whatever it's nothing it is nothing
they're literally forcing your hand
steering you to purchase you know I'm
saying so at the end of the day it's
just like look you know this is what it
is with this money thing they gotta fix
that to have cool stuff earning game but
if they if this is what it is with all
this money remembered remember what was
the remember Luke Smith what was the one
of the UM the things he came out with he
said write director's cut right and
remember the director's cut he said hey
with the money we made here we was able
to give you um Trevor and the such a
judgment that better happened next seize
it cuz dawning is out here in
everybody's pockets next season I better
see whisper 2.0 level quest I want to
see something because I'm giving you our
halftime right I like the story
narrative beats but the content is light
you gotta do something you gotta do
something otherwise we're gonna see this
stuff like you see know what you're
doing
you're gonna see the tweets from glad
you're gonna see the stuff from from
Port a/c and that's when when you start
pissing all car off you know how we get
we start we'd be like all right we won't
play you gonna see people streaming
division or whatever game it is that was
the hot not a muff game not division but
whatever flavor of the muff new game
comes out you will see the streamers
over there so they gotta be careful that
that's all I'm saying I'm confident that
they are going to do the right thing
I am I I'm not too worried this time but
it is interesting to see people chirping
you know say and I want to see how they
handle it and the last thing is um I
will give him
you know I've talked that noisy in my
PvP I don't want to go on my PvP rank
cuz you know how I feel
I'll talk all day it's it's trash it's
not rewarding there's no incentive
there's no rewards equivalent to the PvE
we get it you know they also gonna have
to reconsider the pinnacle thing because
the rituals ain't it I'm sorry I don't
like the rituals I I have no incentive
for the ritual
it's literally basic archetype guns with
an extra perk that you can swap
see
the discussion of casualization yeah
yeah let's go
those are the rewards like two casual
exotics aren't really standing out
mm-hmm a little bit most of your
incentive antics are like hey why am I
gonna use this one cuz it's an
unstoppable one I can actually use it in
my play style not be forced to do
legendaries and stuff and I don't like I
still don't like exotics in the past I
don't like you know I okay please
are you with me another one do not give
me an exotic in the season pass
you with me of course I am I said that
from the start
okay good always fighting on that one
when it first I don't know like there's
only one exotic car it's only in no not
the Ingram's what do I know you're right
you're right no my don't give me the
exotic Ethel you don't give me the
weapon when I log in on day one what
what the hell is that
yeah I don't like it I don't like that I
get it's like cemetary pam pam if there
was a journey to earn that gun as cool
as it actually is double tap you switch
over you get more rounds on the weapon
those Nia shots hit like if you get that
15 X multiplier you just start
vaporizing grabs of enemies from like a
highway what you eat I don't necessarily
like an exotic quest for everything
either sometimes I miss something into
the water drop yes yeah you like oh
what's that okay cool yeah we got to
chat so I'm fine we gotta hit these Chad
is on fire with us right now tit we got
to go back up a little bit I'm telling
you they were on fire sis um hey HD bro
everybody's on it alright let me start
with um okay I saw before tasty I think
the seasonal offering is a great middle
ground for the whole community so he
about a month to get the rank 100 on the
season pass holder committee he's in
close to that if you don't burn through
the content you still have things to do
and then HD gamer bro says I've been
lurking and I agree with everything
you're saying however I don't think of
the seasons as halftime but it's content
add-ons you know I'm saying you want to
get get frost frost is he he on fire too
you see frost or the problem should it
be harder to get the next level which
would make the higher high level raids
dungeons more valuable yes mm-hmm
I was like one and that's the thing as
soon as we see this model the pinnacles
lose it and here's the piece like why is
it always been the issue like the grind
to that highest level those last 50
levels well we got there to a point
before but now it's like you as you set
the expectation if we just get the
little tins every time mm-hmm the other
seasons you're like what the hell am i
going for pinnacles for yeah that's
another reason was like why would I not
if I knew the only honestly I wish they
would have left it at once
mmm left it oh you wouldn't refer to one
but the problem with the one you're
right with the woman the only thing is
they didn't have enough it felt like
they didn't have enough then they should
have told you that 950 to 960 could have
been all year hmm or what I mean I
however it was handled I think as Paul
Tassie said like this is the worse of
the two because now you need a 10 level
bump you have the twos so the people who
grind hard are gonna give it quick the
casuals it's still far but then the
casuals are like it's far enough
do I care in three months that it's
gonna be null and void and I can just
get it with powers again let me let me
challenge you a foretaste a he's saying
we play too much we burn through the
content - what about what about the
answer to that like whatever is this
just in hard core problem and
it's tough right cuz it's like we all
are cool he's not wrong we are the
hardcore but at the same time I'll
answer a little bit it says that if you
lose us we're the guys that keep the
casuals to play we're the guys that say
hey it's it's good right now season is
is on fire right now like it's a tough
one where do you think you think you
think they still got up please it's not
played that much I'm making videos and
seeing like my season passes are like 15
people like you're only at 50 yeah I
mean the dawning is an easy way to get
exp if you want to but then you just be
in the UPS man the word or in death
stranding of destiny yeah they give a no
packages out yes I'm making deliveries
all day man I'll like do every delivery
in the tower until my five repeatable
czar other planets Yago probably do
sundial a couple times you know bill a
mess master or whatever weapon rules I
want then I'll fly to the planets come
back clear those whirls out to a
run-through in the tower again and I'm
just like in to me
I'm not getting that much I am just
getting exp which especially what I like
when tasks he said he got 292 man I
would be hard-pressed to be playing
right now yeah he had enough he has
enough fractal line for whatever is
probably gonna come what I was coming
yeah he's got 92 depending on if he's
got his grinds done I would literally be
like why am i logging in mmm if you're
not going hard after pinnacles hmm
because either you already did it
because it's too fast
if you hardcore it you're like 970
because you have nightmare hunts that
you can do on multiple characters you've
got a raid that you can probably do on
multiple characters you've got enough
ways to get high or the hardcore they're
gonna go fast
the casuals look at the pinnacle and be
like these aren't match made activities
I may not have known many people I can
play with use me
we're life um yeah but you the casual
looks at that but they also know okay
this season both got bumped up ten will
do I try and like find these people and
get like a raid group run they don't
know me I'm not entirely sure I can't
even go match make a sundial which is
not that friggin hard in legend to get
one pinnacle the dungeon could be so
loud but most aren't gonna do that but
then they also know in three months all
that effort you put in to find your
groups of the pinnacle maybe I go bash
my head on a solo non head of heresy
which gives me a [ __ ] role anyway sorry
language all that stuff and then you
come back and then you get to the next
season three months of pinnacle work is
voided yeah cuz you reset the artifact
you go back or so you either do it ultra
fast as a hardcore group or you may as
well just wait and not worry about it
and not worry about it right sure I want
to get a cup of coffee as well fire shot
the coma to Komodo was a slap in the
face to the pvp community I agree you
know say it did alright
say freeze on fire he said ritual
weapons are an excuse for Bungie not
releasing broken weapons and having at
unum I agree
now Frost he's like don't faded engrams
ruin the random drops of exotics um the
only reason why I disagree with that for
us is that um I feel that the way they
have it set up with faded Engram only
working for like the season before
exotics I'm cool with that so that the
new ones that's in the wild are not part
of that the fingers Ingram from Sur yeah
gives you the new stuff they give you
the new stuff out yes I don't even know
that I got Bombardier sperm it last week
the fact you said Bombardier may be like
yeah Bombardier is something but yeah oh
well toy let's talk about these let's we
talk about they're speaking of exotics
we're talking elephant no these these
new ones this is the dawn exacts it's an
armored trash defeating a guardian with
a melee attack or finisher unleashes a
damaging explosion
so if I'm a lay somebody bro or I finish
enemies in PvE I get a little poof yeah
that dad's track that what you should
see see the exotic boots I got for the
Warlock oh I know those when in dawn
blade kill someone and a rift appears
yeah like what what does it benefit you
to have a rift appears the way or Dave
died oh yeah that was a rift need to
need to appear at an enemy's location
oh I don't literally like if you are in
daybreak and you defeat somebody should
make it at your location or at least
that your floor location if you're
floating in the air like however why is
it at the enemy's location I don't
understand who thought what what was the
function at who thought like yo this is
gonna be all there's an enemy on my
teammate I'm gonna save you does that
come up that you're gonna save your
buddy and give them a rift yeah it's
just awful exotic so that - right there
you know look
they're in a tough spot um next season
you know we definitely got it we got to
see something for the hakko we got to
see something because right now as it
stands yes you know I mean that we're
gonna tap out very quickly and it is
there is concern I'm looking at that uh
that season map and I'm looking at
January 7th which is legend sundial and
that was run where we are this is the
week we are we have one more week of
substance yeah in discussions unless a
nob nobody ain't doing backflips over
Chris today's a nobody wrote aureus Lee
we it only lasted for a week so it's
short-lived if you're trying to earn
anything in there mmm you've got the
empyrion foundation on the fourth what
should that is that will be something
but if Bastion is similar in like
whether it's a grind or not it's one
quest we still don't have you know time
and we've got January March 10th and
you've got that one little box of
Imperium foundation floating on an
island in the middle and nothing else
around it that really low what about it
for a minute what about what cover to is
saying what about if they pull the old
you already hide something and we we do
get between them two weeks of random
thing pops up you're like yo and we get
a little bit of a you know saying like a
little outbreak prime kind of a moment
where something pops off cuz that is a
long time without nothing it is a long
time like but I'm gonna say I mean
timing wise it feels like that six-month
cadence but you know damn well they're
gonna put in one Iron Man in it let's
call it right now yeah there's gonna be
a couple of EAJA ban in there but again
do I care to grind for like four
pinnacles to get me a level if I'm
really not loving iron banner or there's
nothing really there's no new weapons
the armors three years old
mmm so like again why
if I hand all of my all of my mods from
those things all my Nan's mom's already
got a whole day spas mm-hmm so that's
done my season rolls the season pass
already has better armor than I'm
guaranteed to probably ever get from
iron banner even mm-hmm though those
void PV girls are good mm-hmm
options here bud hey my god and if my
season passes at 92 and I'll probably
casually get up to 100 of those last
eight levels to at least finish it up
because I don't care about triumphs
level 207 or whatever stupid thing that
is ooh why am I going into iron banner I
don't have incentive none lots of things
in this game are not incentivized and
it's like I was talking with some people
in chat and shout out to Prescott and
bender and quite a few that we did the
legend heroic with we were playing tag
in the tower by the way no I was playing
hide and seek actually that is exists I
put on a pink shader on the most shiny
crap that I could wear and then I was
like alright turn off your hood this was
just like a trust thing but they didn't
find me for a while so Israel mm-hmm and
we played tag while we were talking
that's hilarious
so we did I did the quest we did Legend
sundown like what else we need to do I'm
like we are creating most sure sure out
of boarding boredom a little bit of chat
- it's like a giggle oh shoot it's like
the brightness gonna me personally has
pushed me away from the game and
seasonal engrams before the continued
player to ensure that I got everything I
wanted but with that without that it's
not there when I'm trying to still catch
up the catalyst on those exotics are
pretty lengthy on the new exotics yeah
you get you get an exotic handed to you
yet the exotic catalyst is forever long
yeah 400 rounds of BS is just like yeah
it's very great just let me kill stuff
with it I don't care if like symmetry
I've got to get a thousand kills with
each style that's still gonna go faster
than the 400 what is this like a whole
bunch of gambit matches or something
it's just matter it's like gambit
cruisers like in activity playlist
activities just like
just checking a box and but you have to
check it like four hundred times which
is mmm breezy shadow the Forte with the
Tier one stuff think closed-loop foot
hmm
Chad I'm trying to get there so go but
yeah it's like sir hasn't had much love
in ages
yes Ernie oh man he's he's a rework bad
there's definitely no incentive to go
and then you know would unless we talk
about the elephant in the room again you
know with the exotics with the RNG upon
RNG upon RNG okay so I'm gonna say this
right now people already set it to
exotics need an omni seasonal slot
I'm tired of late for what I'm around
can't use weapons with your C's I can't
pull out graviton Lance mm-hmm and be
like hey I want to use a pulse rifle
then has anti barrier just to use it in
activity and hey I want to grind out my
catalyst on it so I'm gonna use it in
some of these strikes and they've got
barriers and we're doing it you know
what I do this balance they don't want
us to be too overpowered you know what
is this gun overpowered no is the gun no
it's not I agree we're so then why can I
use it in an activity - Oh unstop
overload or break a barrier with the
stability of balance but it's not broken
they wear it if they're worried about
I'm tell you what it is they're worried
about the intrinsic effects of these
exotics with the let's just use graviton
you know it has that explosion or
whatever right they're worried that some
type of combination with berry or
whatever is gonna melt you know they
might on this uh smelting stuff that's
the new thing we can't have them melt we
can and again shout to low no he's got a
great he had a great video but he made a
good point he like look I'm not the
biggest fan of melting either but I will
say the point made was this that if
guardians up of we call the community
comes up and fires and puts in the work
to find these perfect strats and
combinations right
there is something to be said I'm gonna
enjoyment of being rewarded for finding
these things out right now yes there has
to be balance there has to be a line not
everything can be melted but it also
comes back to what we said when they
went through the orb generating nerfs
right you've now made skull of die on my
car all these things completely useless
now right there's no reason because
you've nerfed it so hard so again
they've gotta find a better balance you
don't say so I'm with you I would love
these exotic weapons to have anti
barrier overall I don't think that's
gonna break I don't think that's gonna
change how fast you kill anything I
think they were done I think based on
look at the patterns the patterns tell
you look at what's happened from ritual
I mean pinnacle to ritual the pattern
then why the hell do we even have
exotics hey talking he preached into
quiet now I was like whoa if you think I
can use a weapon normally in say a raid
well where there aren't that many
champions if any known number but say
you're in there and I've got a raid
going on and you say it's okay for me to
use graviton Lance I'm just using that
as an example cuz it is not overpowered
I know it is oh is it Nagi with its high
barrier oh my god I know how Bungie
peaks with bungees like no no no here's
this example this is why I'm on this
okay go for it vagabond Oh gift and subs
thank you very much is Nagi with the
anti barrier
okay so take the way people do is the
anti barrier with izanagi's what is your
you either all you're doing is again
using a mode to break a trail shoe to
friend to stop a function you're not
killing them faster if anything you're
wasting your sniper ammo to break a
shield but in fairness II if multiple
people have izanagi with anti barrier
boom boom and missile they have multiple
with izanagi's without it and they kill
it so the anti barrier doesn't affect it
this is my point about this like those
anti barrier anti champion anti unstart
like unstoppable Pro those champion mods
will not a free exchange of father's
knows best
no [ __ ] you cannot justify to me the
putting an anti barrier on graviton
Lance is gonna break the game nobody I
don't even think nobody's gonna show me
where that breaks the game I know how
father thinks I've studied them in tango
how about of the game cuz you're ruining
hearing us they they don't like us grab
listen bro recluse
we've got mountains like Dave don't I'm
not listen I'm mostly more powerful than
it's not it yeah I am agree all I'm
saying is bro uh I know how they move
they like you know if they get a hold of
that you know we're not gonna be able to
control them and the content they're
gonna get rid of these bosses are so
fast they don't think about this you
don't know how to eat we know how to
move look what you glad do something how
quickly we go get it to the bed they are
they slower the meta right guns in the
vault they ain't getting no burn nobody
uses come on a Bungie buff it fix it
oh yeah we'll get to it we we've
documented your feedback we we're
listening that's what you hear right
we're listening soon
we break something effective immediately
one caress effectively turned off but
nonetheless though it's off until
further notice we are quick with the
babe
that's how do you move it I'm not saying
it's right I just know they are not
giving us that that fun that we want
with with those exotics have a nose
that's what not if they think the gun
works without the mods the mods don't
break anything else that is my point
like I understand you don't want them
nerfing this doesn't change the speed of
these this literally lets you have
variation in your loadout that's all I'm
asking for it does like I show me the
testing where this breaks the game it's
not going to it's not gonna melt
anything it's not gonna break anything
well in their defense I'm just be I got
it I got a play devil's advocate just
gonna lie to me how an outside barrier
round on whatever Lance know on on that
give me a give me example I grab the
stance is gonna work they're gonna say
Oh salute to summon a chat salute
they're gonna say
well we haven't tested the full effect
of the third explosion you know and what
that can do and they a whole thing like
for example I don't know shut up you
have you tested have you tested graviton
Lance to dying till it's dying day in
the past two and a half years isn't that
gun in the PvE sandbox where you want it
you just buffed it by 20%
yeah they buffed it okay so obviously it
wasn't even that great in the first
place and it still fires Ellis Loew so
we in those moments you have void
shields cool you get to shoot them hey
you hit somebody with that thing you get
the cosmology perk they think that's in
a good spot hey you're against an anti
barrier shoot a few times with anti
barrier shields gun gun functions the
exact same way all it does is literally
give you a different choice to fight a
champion curve that is essence champions
are the new thing game developer hat and
we gotta be real now right we don't know
how things work in the background right
let's be real weird developers I got my
guess I'm the Pope today I'm gonna pull
bars on the Pope so we don't know how
they were all right so their thing is
like look same thing with Telesto so
let's go keep having a problem you shoot
at the ground give your super does this
give you super it does that there's
certain guns for whatever their special
effect is has other things that break
other aspects of the game I think they
just worry I'm not saying what you're
saying is wrong I know how they are
there's certain things that for whatever
reason in the coding breaks other stuff
and I think exotics board another
because let's be real exotics do special
boombastic things right so their whole
thing is if we put it on that oh my god
now we got to account for five other
problems and they like yo let's not even
do it let's have them mess with these
legendaries and that's it they play it
safe do I agree with it no do i what I'd
like to have represented yes mmm
has become so focused on not breaking
thing yes ruined my way is is Ryan for
anything in the game I don't simply get
on shine new roles for the same guns
chat which flippin I'm or don't think
I'm not with a oh I am NOT saying I am
disagreeable please don't think I'm
against them I'm just putting on a
bungee had to tell him what they're
going
tell him when he gonna summit they go
tell him I'm not going there all summit
you go into something we're gonna get
them to the summit yard this is one of
the best destiny concentrate it's
beginning to something there's when he
goes to this summit he gonna be like
that Jim I want my damn why an armor and
miss and they gonna say
mister you know due to the technical
challenges of the cosmology perk you
know this could affect three different
subclasses and you know as a result we
just couldn't take that risk no say so
previously in your testing with the
graviton landing itself in all
activities between rains in PvP in
strikes has your coma is your cosmology
working as intended currently yes
outside of champions yes okay so they go
in say black that the technical layer of
the of the barrier presents a new
challenge in the code okay to be smart
that's not working they go hit you with
the technical BS is about how these
extra layer of barrier doesn't work mess
up this would work though because they
already say the gun is OK right now if
you're gonna tell me that gun is sitting
in a place where you buffed it by 20%
you think it's okay in the Medi there's
nobody walking about it the fact that
it's it they added champions to the game
they want this to be the new thing where
you fight these champions in different
ways mmm-hmm okay I've also got an
entire collection of exotic weapons
we're gonna be rotating through remember
these things if it's broken for three
months mm-hm slap from there bungees
technical and choice mouths of all the
higher up saying Haven broke given three
months you know it's not gonna stay
around forever so if they put a pulse
rifle anti barrier mod in there and
somehow graviton breaks it god forbid
it's gonna break it or they'll do when
they didn't work god Chris and turn it
off II so this is the point where
they're taking the fun too far away
mm-hmm
let it let the experiments happen and
I'm using graviton Lance because I know
it's weak and no it's not that strong
and all it's literally going to do is
like unstoppable oh if you get that like
one burst ATS the same way Mike it's
gonna function the exact same way my go
figure is it's just if I get a kill it's
gonna get its exotic function out of it
the champions are not are something that
we have to deal with now we can't say
for sure we know in deface we can't say
for sure we know it won't break we
unreasonable gamer know I have watched
them with graviton Lance be like hey
it's okay you saw with me AP hey it's
okay I got a 20% buff in PvE recently
they're actually trying to get people to
use this weapon but then they give you
no wait no functionality to use it
because no exotics except seasonal buds
how are you gonna be like hey you've got
these weapons you might want to check
out that vigilance wing you're gonna
tell me vigilance wing that doesn't even
have a cosmology it just has five shot
bursts no for sure
we got ticks we don't know for sure I
agree no okay because how a champion
works it has a show here we go grungy
they bungee that he knows bungee no II
know Jacques oh he's telling you he can
do this free of charge and show you how
to implement this if you wanna hire a
programmer and a weapon specialist my
man either cheater he's got you baby
be nice give that one just just was just
given the fake benefit of the doubt that
we may haven't tried it either
like I have a collection of exotics okay
yeah so is hand cannons last season you
couldn't use sunshine would you have
liked to hone out a bit fire
what is Sun shot broken no well what
would I do with it I would be
unstoppable it would literally one every
other guys would explode huh okay I hit
him with an unstoppable everything else
functions the same that's what I'm
saying the champions and the anti
barrier in the ant those mods are not
game breaking it's just a literal it's a
challenge within a year and they're not
gonna change the functionality the
explosions the damage you do when you do
those you don't even hardly do damage
you don't get the cosmology perk to
activate
you're literally linking working on a
shield you're working on a slowdown send
trigger guy something for us they say
Ariana's vile intrinsically has anti
barrier route
it isn't game breaking they make you
some points there he's making some
points and then I'm leviathans breath
intrinsically has unstoppable yeah
making some points making some points
but I think to be honest I think that's
what they try to do to us so they just
that's a different argument is my point
so if you're saying break in the game no
are they forcing us into other exotics
that's a very different argument and
that's unfortunately like they tried
they trying to give new exotics that
functionality so that they have value
you have to lay this way yes they try to
pigeonhole you and that big decision I
don't agree with that either but it's
like to say that you can't put it you
can't put a slot on those other guns
mm-hmm and have a choice to toy with
them during a season yeah that's not
gonna hurt anything no no you're under
something they're definitely on to
something it's just funny that they're
so protective you know that they're so
here's you know you can't it's it's a
great time to use it scouts are good
yeah it'll be dope to pull out like you
said the Polaris's and and gnome
whatever good scouts that just would
have been using Jade what if I had a
horrible fight with odd with around
max I mean so that's that's the whole
point of like we have armor that gets
nerfed into the ground it doesn't get
changed you don't have a crown of a
skull of dire ahankara that's like hey
you know what we are changing the
mentality of how we do orb generation we
don't want you guys like refilling
supers then change how the exotic
completely functions works give it
another surface don't just be like hey
I've got an exotic my vault that you
know somewhere isn't worthy this is
where they deny me this is where they
need to hire me with that they need to
give Tuesday love numbers and analytics
right they need to let me have the
numbers of the most underperforming
exotics and I'm gonna come with a spread
shot at the end of the month and say yo
you see these three right here twelve
yeah no look at the percentage of usage
no one's using these as Titan hunters
warlocks whatever let's start with armor
right and then build ourselves back up
so that they they stay had what I like
that they're doing is like the solar
week I mean I said we put the solar is
like the the the the whole subclass meta
buff I like that I know you laughed at
Ark week but I did like the concept of
the underutilized Ark subclasses getting
buff through the roof oh yeah girls need
it just don't call it in a bin but yeah
I mean that's know like subclasses
getting like reviews and the time it
takes for testing be like alright we're
focused on solar Oh playtesting and
subclass team and all that stuff you
guys are working on these subclasses
getting on a lot of you see how we can
tweak them to make them better yeah that
stuff is totally agree that stuff should
definitely happen that was great right
it just needs to happen with armor and
that's the problem
armor gets nerfed you never hear
something anything gets enough for the
most part you never hear from it again
they're not looking clearly at the
statistical usage rate to bring them
back into play and hello sleeper
simulant is its tread non-red around
trending on reddit it was like yo it's
been nerfed so hard as a result of
gambit and all these other things and
then linear fusion rifles right now get
a buff I mean line in the sand all these
other things are outperforming it's it's
pathetic
and I'm saying and that's one of the I
would say hardest to get but we have to
admit sweeper simulant was a task
there was a lot of steps involved yes so
the same thing you know we've had the
conversation with whisper they got to
revisit things I hate that they nerf and
forget and that's it you don't hear from
these things ever again and it's on to
the new stuff and it's saddening you
know I'm saying they they gotta they
have to do something about that and
that's the thing I'm not going to
relinquish on that let me get a frost
real quick what if X armor armor could
be classified into buffing you buffing
teammates nerfing enemies it's out of
gloves that convert mob enemies into
allies it's not a boost that buff
teammates you walk in your footsteps
yeah I mean I that doors are part of you
know what I like that's a good point for
us you know a perk I love that they
added the firing line
I thought firing line is dope like you
get your heavy line in the sand if you
have two other guardians with you that
increases the damage per shot that's
dope boss melting raids dysfunctionality
the other they didn't want boss melting
well you know as a result you know you
make a perk that literally makes you
line up to melt a bus
no well correction correction what they
don't like is boss melting stacking
strategies right that's what they all
Hawker
okay you wouldn't have melting is
finding close together in a well over
bespoke employee we used to boo the boss
then we used to someone with the tight
we have the well irradiance did somebody
we never let your firing line sniper and
go to town we'd have like four DeVos
working at once they don't want that now
they just want whatever's the highest
buff to work and then everything else
get eliminated there's that's to do
general but individual keeping firing
line would still work because it's
individual per weapon right but any of
that group stuff for the most part they
want I'm cool there but I like stuff
like that - what frost is saying like I
like totally developing a boss that
kills all six of you with one attack
because you're standing on the same damn
spot yeah you know Tambo what's this one
oh you all grouped together firing on me
well I'm gonna shoot a lightning bolt
down and kill all six of you because
you're on the same spot I'm just waiting
for that boss to get developed me like
up firing line screwed on this box right
never mind
don't stand together you gotta be
separated the closer you are there's a
bus the closer you are together the
board damage you take you just negate
that entire just wait until that thing
shower to cover to cover to say it
exactly what I've been saying he said
I'm just curious how much not having
high Moon and vicarious vision it's
affecting Bungie right now it's more
than we think I agree
I'm not arguing that mmm that is that is
for sure we are gonna have lighter
seasons now the other thing when we
think about next season what's gonna be
coming we don't know the activity we do
we don't know where the narrative goes
mm-hmm without major changes though do
you think you really
want trials right now or do you think
yes rose to glasses yes I don't want to
hear about that
we don't want trials because the
community in the game is not listen
we have this fate you know how easy it
is to cheat on PC right now bro I
understand that's why they came out
we're gonna get to the twelve this is
what I'm trying to say there is no
scenario where it's gonna be perfect
they don't have dedicated servers nope
let's just call it what it is when
trials was at its heyday dudes was
paying dudes to carry them to the
lighthouse when he could cheat so let's
not act like when trials was in this
golden state that everything was all
hunky-dory
it was always busted there was always
shenanigans going on where people go
into the lighthouse let's just call it
what it is all I'm saying is PvP
community damn it we are old we have
been suffering with no pinnacle activity
for them longer I don't want to have the
Sun needs to shine this direction it has
to be the perfect temperature for
transfer this is no worry
give me my trials could do you this is
my worry if you guys get trials but it
doesn't live up to what is that memory
in the back of your mind if they don't
nail it because trials of the nine did
listens because they would be foolish
and adding four players in eliminating
elimination the essence of trials is
elimination and the map that's if
they've got the match they got the moon
put it in there the only thing they
gotta do is the correct pinnacle weapons
the reward has to be round much of you
guys switch ancestors come out play a
lot a minute I'll be playing a total
limit let's go what what I'll be ready
I've been ready yes and it's fantastic
for me to hear and I just want to hear
say Cyrus's voice the Saints voice bring
me my trials is it's not gonna be
perfect we know this I'm just saying you
got to understand when trials is at its
when it's right it's about sustaining
the base on that weekend during dead
periods you don't say but there has to
be Lou I agree cover two you got to have
loo the loo has to be right it has to be
those we got to have our doctrine of
passings we got to have those fly trials
weapons that you like oh my god this
weapon is amazing where did you get it
trials has to have that I'm which order
when
right it is the most one of the most
addicting things in the game and you
give let's look at the numbers right now
here's the problem with the people who
say oh it shouldn't come back
pull up Charlemagne and look at the
stats on PvP from when shadow keep
started - now it is pathetic it went
down from length 400 less than 400,000
something some ridiculously low it is
anemic right now to PvP no one's playing
PvP you've got to give PvP a shot at arm
whether you like it or not we're in a
war with pvp and PVE okay so what we're
gonna bring it back one loot is going to
fit into their perfect little bubble of
not too strong but going to be worth it
in trials right now then put something
put it exotics in it they gotta do
something I put enemy to soar pinnacle
weapons hexagon
look at you look at you know it's like
this is like this is a question like
whether it ok sofa cut if elimination
feels good
if the fries feel alright if the mappers
are okay it still comes back to why are
you doing it you had your special
doctrines of passing that we're like
great in the meta like do you pictured
them being able to put
loot in the game does gonna incentivize
it well you know you tell you the easy
way to fix this repackage in Weston
what's to try they always do a dust off
to all guns put them dust them off and
put back in the game with a new name
like they always do they always
repurpose some old stuff that we've
already seen you'll say and bring it
back we've got like so many of the old
d1 guns came back already
ughter sitting on trials weapons it's
sitting on a bunch of stuff that
surrounds weapons back Hey if they can't
think of something no but hey you got
the old dust of choice out the Attic
just doctoring a pass hanging down
you're basically not gonna be as good as
it was it's basically steel feather
repeater with you know is that right now
but you can use any people you got
managed to be haven't rolled look at
that come on man a signal weapons bro
they signal so they could easily bring
that stuff back I'm telling you they're
gonna get it rap if they reskin d1 I'm
just saying at the end that's the
rewards there's definitely a reason what
of the day they've reskin all the PvE
Stein nobody you I'm not saying I love
you people complaining PvP we will not
complain people love those weapons
weapons crazy oh my god
doctrines back you can have for Fallout
plays videos and ask the cross go come
on it's nasty baby I'm telling you
people are gonna go crazy it's gonna be
me again is it ever going to be what it
was I don't know all I'm saying is they
they cannot have these anemic numbers
people like PvP people aren't exiting
the game in droves this is no incentive
that's not what I need something if
trials is there isn't ready it does need
something I'm gonna agree with that like
they I mean and then also every like
I'll think about doing I'll do like
weekly Rhea Seddon be like gambit now
just like laugh and my head that hasn't
been touched since drifter and probably
I don't know when that would get changed
like would you do and all would you do
that changed the gambit or is it just
literally gonna be the month of them
doing
turtle testing be like well we decided
on this one mode that's it yeah well one
of them was going but it was like it's
making it through this year though yeah
yeah shouts a selfie I hope they don't
do a renewal of the old trials armlet
yeah I hope so
actually I do I want the Egyptian stuff
please that's what I prefer I don't care
for that season and uh whatever crap
[ __ ] crazy nine stuff that go ahead give
me my Egyptian armor I want to look like
a pharaoh that is some of the coolest
thing give me the chrome and give me or
they could literally reskin verbatim all
the old trial stuff I would go crazy
that's how much I want it back it's
gonna come back there
well I definitely say we
topic but we covered quite a few things
today it's been interesting because
there are opinions about this game on
both the hey I don't get to play that
much - this actually feels ok if this
quest is easy to get hey I believe all
the time this took me five minutes well
now what am I gonna do for my entire
Tuesday that I plan to play all day
you're gonna have both sides of the
equation
you're gonna PvP that's not happy you're
gonna PvE they can't use their perks on
their exotic like me you're gonna have
all these arguments over things that
Bungie of course has a tough job to do
but they they are in a trend right now
of making some decisions where the
harder stuff does seem to be falling
away and that's that's concerning to a
lot of people whether it's is that
recluse Ryan that you have to go for 21
Fable and you got to get the ring easier
to get there now that's - wouldn't even
be that bad they might need to move it
up a little bit is the quest for an
exotic that you put on your calendar
that takes you 30 minutes should that be
or what if that was just a surprise you
finished your first sundial run for that
what I would almost rather have that I
would almost rather have had Devils run
ruin and be at the end of the universe
I'll just populace and then the words I
hate go to a sundial go get it quick
it's like it's an easy quest but it's a
new gun just like managing the
expectations either make something small
a surprise you make it have a catalyst
and make the catalyst you get it from
that to something yeah yeah anything
else to it and then yeah we get these
exotics and we won't see catalyst for
them for a year
we're just getting catalysts for like
Black Talon that's been in the game for
a year net like since swords came in and
now 13 14 months later we give a
catalyst Lord and we're like that's
that's still a weapon they ever forgot
about it yeah so a weird state right now
but I've set up a board yes I will say
it again if you're not loving your time
jump up during the busy times take a
break and play other things cuz if you
guys see me doing streams and it doesn't
say destiny might happen
hahaha listen I I think it's half time
y'all I just think it I think we need to
chill III hey everyone I'm with everyone
no one is wrong all I'm saying is we did
just come off of shadow key
you know we do realize the resources of
what it is next season needs we need to
start the paracord up there is a we need
to get that going and have at least one
or two you know substantial pieces of
content in conjunction with the season
and hopefully if they can do that model
I'll let them off the hook more but we
can't have another season of no raid no
dungeon no difficult activity and then
expect people to stick around that I'm
with you like we do the exact same
format and I like to be honest I'm gonna
be Rama surprise you I do like this
season I do like it narrative Lee I do
like the things that they've done with
story progression and saint-14 has been
an amazing character I've loved the way
they've handled him and we've got more
narrative Beach than we've ever gotten
out of them all I'm saying now is that
you know for the next season let's get
back closer probably gonna be a full
ledge
you know shadow keep typing stay in
fashion but let's get closer to a
menagerie expansion but I'll put it this
way I will say and I want your luxury we
know but let's just say we let's just
say this though I'm gonna ask you a
question
because I redo my incidence I still feel
out of this Annual Pass format Menagerie
is number one still out of all of them
that we've had so far
yep
I got season Adorno but what do you feel
is number two
think of throne for drifter opulence
undying dawn
of the seasons yeah
probably opulence dawn Forge
for undying
you're still better than undying
yeah you got you got you got lights
outside whoo that's alright but ya know
for me I mean dawning hasn't been bad
we've had donning season and Dawn sorry
you different thing
sundials not a bad activity we got
rotating bosses as an upgrade from vex
defensin though little variation there I
wish the bosses were in different rooms
I think that would be a thing that could
be potential late cuz always going like
where's the boss it doesn't matter what
week it is we're going the same
direction to the boss so every single
boss is in the future I'm like really
why do you got that but I'd like to see
the bosses in a different place that'd
be a variation for later to think about
because you have three arenas let me go
fight a boss in the other two that's
that doesn't seem like a big stretch
yeah I agree that that's a mistake
are we me you talked about that in the
beginning we hope to desolder to UM
Saiyans we're not the same reskin
pattern and no I uh
all it is is like one's got lightning
one's got the little boy bubbles
I believe in fire one is oh yeah Hulse
or whatever
either way it's like just a little more
variety to these bosses and again this
is where the resources maybe the the
lingering thought in the background I
was like is it always just the resources
holding back potential for something to
be decent to be pretty cool like is it
gonna take it up a level if there were
more resources to build to more boss
rooms to a little bit more different
mechanics to them I mean they're Saiyans
but again they feel really similar you
still gotta go you have to go punch the
Sion doesn't matter which one you fight
yeah
like if I didn't trapped in a bubble in
there and trapped in a bubble the void
one made sense it's like okay I could
see this but then if it's like solar
there are there are some wait like what
if there's a guy that just walks out in
the dudes on fire and you got to kill
that guy to go break this just give me
something else just something I agree
laughs and then now we've got you know
Tom if he's the same damn guy and I have
to punch him but I'm just in like the
time shattered realm instead that's
always gonna be that's gonna hurt a
little bit gonna hurt
let's go subtract points there's there's
no there's no doubt about that because
oh but looks like we got a pinnacle now
instead of X offensive never having that
actually losing it's powerful which was
weird which was weighted so you do have
a pinnacle out of that you lose the lake
opulent still wins because you had
weapons and armor even if those older
stuff you had both options yes it picked
but you could truly get armor right now
the armors random role and say if I do
what if I wanted to do a pinnacle but I
wanted to go for a piece of armor right
let me go pick that helm at a pinnacle
role I don't know the stat role don't
make it suck please but right let me
pick a piece of armor instead of just a
weapon like you got the whole set down
there pick one then after that you go
back to the normal weapon picks you know
just make give the pinnacle a little bit
more
I mean fer the world building like the
Saint 14 missions have been awesome
I've been phenomenal is that word them
freaking amazing those were stellar yeah
and then he's in the tower we got the
commentary we got to banter back and
forth which while the quest was boring
itself the banter was really cool though
there was great mm-hmm and then we've
still got this a little bit we don't
know what's Bastian
unfortunately now if Bastian has steps
to it then maybe we won't be getting
lore from it which kind of sucks
so all of this is like they're taken
Beck's offensive they're taking these
other things and they're lighting
there's six to nine months behind the
curve of what they get to learn for
whatever they learned in drifter we
might be seeing some of that now
whatever they learning in opulence we
might be seen at next season so the
progression is slow because they can't
instant fix an entire development cycle
because they have to work on building
environments and enemies and weapons and
things like that and they just have to
stick with what's there and be like hey
we learned this thing mm-hmm
but we're committed over here we got to
just roll with it sorry guys like and
there's only so much you can do I
understand that but it's like we do see
things going yeah I will definitely say
wishful thinking I'm 100% with you
legend needs matchmaking maybe the first
week you don't have it but week - hey
matchmaking is in there done there is no
reason that thing should not have it
tiger
though I mean and that seems to be the
pattern unfortunately with pinnacles
they were using lesser time banner
they're refusing any pinnacles to be
done matchmaker does not like the
dungeon could be done like I don't know
it may not be the best you may have
people leave but at least you might have
a shot to try some of the Ryu
because right now raids are a lot I'll
give them the relax yeah six others oh
there's six there's rolls you got two
different teams doing two sets of things
communication is required but the
sundial riot just kind of survived if
you go back to orbit right again with a
and that's what matchmaking does I agree
as negative today sounds I'm waiting for
Bungie to kick us all in the face and
make us feel bad for questioning them
but we shall see ya a free time listen
man I'm I know you I know I know it
sounds like we Negative Nancy all day
today but we just we got it we got to be
real about the concerns right you know
but I will say yes I do feel next season
or even I'm not completely giving up on
this season because I do feel there's
going to be some type of aha moment I
think we get we get and we get one aha
moment and I do think next season we're
gonna have the substantial content that
the hardcore is missing you know saying
one of it is going to be trials you
don't say that but it has there's rain
if there's try
ooh good question that's a lot of
resources and that's so that's a lot of
development you're like time I don't
date trials is gonna be as difficult as
you may think only for the standpoint
it's being worked on like anymore now
yeah yeah that thing's cooked it's just
a matter of let's get you know mr. fruit
and I'm doing it here whatever them do
is is yours let the dues get in there
rock out are they happy
yeah it's a bit like a dado or a fruit
video and it's like mr. fruit rock I'll
are they pleased are they smiling you
know I'm saying that's what that is they
they they are not they respect trials
enough that they know it has to be done
right and thus when we transition into
this table
why all of a sudden we get in these
cheatin digs it's coming it's coming why
all of a sudden now we're talking about
you know so often yeah security team
will cover has been improving yes these
anti cheat functionality which detects
players violating any of bungees
restrictions and bans
mm-hm the anti cheat improvements will
result in more players are safer
restrictions and bans historically
Bungie has not given players the ability
to appeal a restriction or ban because
all restrictions and bans are already
reviewed by trained Bungie employee
however going forward we were providing
a resource for players to appeal a
restriction or ban if you encounter any
players suspected of cheating please
ensure that use the in-game reporting
tool mm-hmm Bareilles appeals will not
be considered additionally not all
appeals are guaranteed to be responded
to by a bunch of employee as always
closely monitoring but trying to get it
better it's it's bad though right there
are like I don't know if you saw the
Twitter thing there was some time over
break it was the like 10 second delay
before they took like a whole bunch of
fire damage and their whole team died
there's some ugly-looking like cheap
mechanics and stuff going on out there
yeah so and the issue is I think trials
has to be behind the season pass a lot
of people have been saying this and it's
a perfect way to help you gotta pay for
it you cannot pay for a wall in the
world jump in there yeah you can't let
all the freebies play it's like I'm
sorry right I think that's gonna keep it
a lot cleaner I agree I'm with you I'm
with you on that I'm with them on this
you know stepping up to put the police -
Popo ban get that going and um yeah it
looks that's the best thing gonna be
able to do you don't saying because at
the end of the day even during its hey
let's not forget
trials there was still shenanigans there
was still tomfoolery it was still dudes
when you go to their website in their
home I'll take you to the right house
and do all the fools just we're never
gonna avoid that until destiny has
dedicated servers that's just how it is
they've never had that you know I mean
so you're gonna be susceptible that so
they as long as they try to put all
those things in place to mitigate which
is again paywall you got to pay if you
want to play this and yo we banning cats
if you we seeing stuff it's gonna be a
no-questions-asked policy and you're out
of here now if you think it was a
mistake you can try to appeal there's no
guarantee there's basically saying
there's no guarantee you're gonna win
that case but you can try to appeal
music but they busy letting us know they
are going to be more aggressively
monitoring it and that's what that's
what you need man that's the best you
can do in the current you know peer to
peer server environment just sit
hopefully if enough we'll just have to
see it but at least it sets the bar a
little better if we can but yeah there's
not that much else on there they do
actually do a really cool shout-out oh
yeah do everybody in Australia seriously
I am what they are going through with
their wildfires is almost like nothing
we've seen in a while I mean out there
it looks like they're driving through
the apocalypse
it's brutal and then I mean the number
of animals that have died it's that's
absolutely rough stuff people losing
their homes the size of the fire is like
the rainforest in California combined
times three oh those aren't those aren't
small numbers those are giant giant I
mean we're talking half a country that
seems like it's on fire right now though
they are working together to do just as
they've done before like literally
that's why I'm wearing this shirt nah so
that Nepal shirt what happened in Nepal
this was the shirt that they did for the
fundraiser they're getting ready to do
something similar and they're saying
starlight Starbright you can see the
emblem mm-hmm it's got kind of stars and
votes very clean just simple yes like a
North Star guiding light yeah I'm gonna
be doing a donation situation again to
help with all of what's going on in
Australia so stay tuned for that one
we'll probably have more information
next week cause I think that's when
they're gonna kind of finalize the info
on it probably go up in the store so
stay tuned and just
if you could afford to get a shirt 100%
of this I'm sure is all pretty much
gonna go proceeds are gonna go to
Australia so they are struggling right
now I mean you'll see people like Alana
piers from IGN she's out there and
you're just some of the stuff that they
post up there country is just that's
that's a rough place for a country
that's well just burning off big-time
you see some of the videos and pictures
there was one it was just the camera
news guy and he's just like driving down
a road slowly and then you start to
realize what's sitting on the side of
the road and it's just it's rough yeah
mr. Lewman this is this is another good
cause you don't always cool to see
bungee jump ahead of these things and
really you know show that side - as far
as a community coming together to help
out people in need or communities in
need and um this is another this is a
really cool thing that they're doing so
yeah if you can definitely support you
know it it's going to a good cause and
yet people are suffering in certain
places you got it we have to be
cognizant of that so this is cool that
they have recognizing that charge of
summer - oh yes definitely so wrap it up
though there's not much else I mean the
worm guard caressed the fire hammer
they broke raided yeah they broke the
raid boss wait a second glad they find
these ways man but yeah warm guard Chris
fire hammers were like killing bosses in
three seconds I think they killed our
ghost was the one I watched any of them
we're done in seconds so it's been
disabled mm-hmm until they can deploy a
fix the hotfix to point seven point 0.2
is coming next week they are trying to
fix like wish endures getting changed
next week as well it's a good run wish
in the day yeah I like that I like I
mean and that's the same his comment is
that it took it to be that fun for
people to use it and then now it's going
back in the trash can again do sad man
that's because that's how we envisioned
the power of that bowl based on doing
shot at throne we wanted something
boombastic for that and it is that we we
do Felicia peace if it's not gonna be
exactly that level should be some wait a
minute II can't go exactly back to how
it was nobody
again when they nerf not going back not
revisiting this is my thing man rest in
peace wish and it was a good
resurrection while it lasted you would
join the ranks of sleeper simulate and
whisper of the worm and other faithful
exotics that had once had their hey but
now they are forcefully putting you into
retirement that's what's happening baby
that's what's happening salute was a
good friend good rundown mommy other
than that a couple other things will be
there kind of following a couple hot
fixes and then there's montage videos
and stuff so somehow the twelve is ultra
light this week but also worse these are
the weeks when you get rambling about so
much stuff and honestly it's cuz the
community so thank you guys very much
mmm-hmm but yeah that's mostly what we
got we can wrap it up I think this you
got anything else no man that's pretty
much it man I'm you know yeah this was a
short one but as is tradition with the
last word the short Tarbes tend to be
the logger shows mouth shut
target times tend to be the shorter
shows we talk about for whatever reason
they're just fun but it's good to be
talking destiny again we shall see what
happens
stay tuned again not trying to make it a
negative Nancy show but you know we
always got a voice our concerns as
always good talk this man get his
opinion but um we're doing our wrap ups
we'll be doing we don't yeah yeah yeah
for me it's Quirino laura cayouette wit
ha so come check me out there and on our
podcast back again in the new year on
Sundays 1 p.m. Eastern we're back at 1
p.m. Eastern and then we're gonna have
all the in separate ghosts good quality
youtuber very good channel man he's
actually got you to excuse me he's an
audio podcast he's disguise tremendous
he runs a good podcast would be talking
about all the latest things what's going
on in next-generation consoles ps5 x-box
series x nintendo switch what if it's a
pro coming there's some pokemon dlc we
got a lot of stuff going on there so
please check that out we're gonna be
hitting that up and then the last thing
i want to say was again you know salute
to all you guys you know more the gaming
down there you know it site how do you
been a full year you know i'm saying oh
my
we started it say about May no no say
about March 2019 we went it made a go
live and um just to see that the support
has been tremendous you had ancient
Frost was in a chat
these are editor-in-chief you seen dizzy
in here he's another he's our CEO excuse
me co-founded the website with me but um
just to see the support you know and as
a result this wouldn't salute that as
Rizzo the Lords of gaming that net will
be at PAX East as media so I'm extremely
extremely proud of that you know all the
hard work we have a tremendous team of
writers you know I myself write on the
site as well I have any definite article
nine time to Tennessee the Mia Josh
wrote it you know so please you know the
support even you poor taxi gave me a
shout out I made it I made it before
taxi agreed with my article about the
The Devil's ruin quest and about the
lore Astrakhan appreciate it so yeah
check that out man I really appreciate
when you guys look at them we tweet them
he always retreats for me and it means a
lot so if you could spread the word on
that it really means less as we try to
bring more coverage and more stuff to
you guys but that's what I got II of
course in the best for our podcast one
you know Brian vice testing podcasts on
Fridays the last word I mean it's just
goes without saying but everybody just
creeped in the room you know just say
you know about that one they don't need
to be told about that one we don't get
enough critic I feel we don't get enough
credit but salute this Rizzo it's good
to be back first episode of the year it
is on you sir we're gonna find people
friends which got going on uh might be
streaming this weekend as you guys know
I might be shifting the game around or
to trying a couple things we'll see what
the weekend holds but just always a
couple things in the backlog that I
wouldn't mind experimenting with so we
will see what the streams hold you guys
coming on me right here or if you listen
son audio on YouTube twitch TV slash P
pontus find me on Twitter usually kind
of keep up with what I'm up to
trying to get a stream schedule up so at
least a couple days of commitment so you
guys can find me this was one of them
streamed a couple days earlier in the
week so depending on work schedule could
be crazy for me but it will try and get
at least a couple days out there for you
guys so follow twitter the youtube my
youtube channel as well if you haven't
subbed there my community tab will keep
you guys updated what's going on so
thank you guys past 45
thousand subs 5k away from the big 50 so
again thank you guys that support
wouldn't be anything but without you
guys so we gotta get him to the summit
so he could tell Bungie how to do these
weapons how he knows how they need to be
done that's the goal y'all yes I'm gonna
say I know all
yes graviton easy knowing can be it's
super easy Carly and Inc V I just I just
think it might be an okay experiment I
feel like you'd be okay all the top of
screen read some of Air Force career
it's super hash tag so easy Holly it it
convenes watches fixing exotics with
minds let them code is no II okay I'll
get right on that
no but yeah that's a bunch yeah I know
it's not easy what you guys do but I do
think that would be a reasonable
experiment still yeah so for guys this
has been episode 86 I'm gonna send you
guys over to modern try hard give him a
hello from us he's working on quite a
bit of fun stuff this morning so more
love in the Destiny community please go
spread the love for episode 86 it is
January 10th you guys have been amazing
thank you for the follows the likes the
subs and everything that you guys do for
us we appreciate it so for this episode
it has been the last word
you